hey there's a steel on chop with
Collider and I am here with Robert
ortigas hey man good to see you again
nice to see you
before we get started we're here in your
hometown I want to give you a huge shout
to all the sponsors that helped us be
here because like hint water and blue
moon and everybody because without them
we would not be able to do these
interviews and not be able to be in
Austin so huge thank you
right um so before we get started into
why I get to talk to you today at South
by as I've said repeatedly how much I
loved Aleta I just wonder he thinks I
just want to say one more time I've seen
it far too many times in the theater and
I just want to say what a great job you
did thank you I know that it's done very
well international I think it did very
well in China yeah like how has it been
doing it can tell fans like how it's
done and stuff it's done you know my
movies don't usually perform like that
overseas I know Jim's does and it's
really exciting to travel the world and
see the reaction in different cultures
and see them just go bonkers for the
movie and it's it's a world stage now so
you can't just I always thought very you
know I'm a very home based kind of guy
always thought about the US market and
and if it did well somewhere else that's
great but you know it's really become
you know the biggest market is overseas
actually and these people are so into
movies and so excited about cinema that
you just you know you've got to think
about them well the other thing that a
lot of people don't realize is the
Chinese box office has it's about to
either it's either overtaken or about to
overtake the American box office oh for
sure you've got 60,000 screens that
we've only got like 5,000 years that's
great that is amazing yeah I mean and 26
were in 26 different formats there it
was like a real eye-opener to go there I
was hanging out with Jackie Chan going
you guys got a great set of here that is
pretty amazing real film lovers you know
so it was really exciting to discover
audiences like for the first time and
realize oh yeah I got to be thinking
about this a lot more yeah now that he
sort of toured the world like with the
film and and sort of seeing that
worldwide thing has that actually
changed your mindset
for future projects like totally totally
yeah cuz you you love for your movies to
be seen and enjoyed so and you've got a
whole audience that you weren't even
thinking about you want to think about a
movie that can play to a global audience
and that's what Jim has always did so
that's why I really wanted to work with
him he made movies that would play the
whole world and that would affect an
audience everywhere very universal
themes very Universal stories that any
culture would think it was made for them
and so it's a different way to design
it's a different creative challenge
designed something that actually could
play in different cultures it's actually
you know makes a lot of sense to think
that way for people that know you they
will know that you did to raise money
you did some medical stuff yes whenever
younger and so talk a little bit about
why you're here and a little bit about
your history with that and how this all
came together for this new project it's
very strange you know if you live long
enough you start to see repeats and
patterns and full circles and this was
one of those times it was a 25th
anniversary of El Mariachi it just got
me thinking about the beginning again
and in the beginning to pay for that
movie you know here in Austin they have
an in big college towns they have these
medical research hospitals because you
have an endless supply of healthy young
specimens that you can bring in that
need money to test any pharmaceutical
has to be tested for like seven years
before can come out here on the market
so yes where you get your test subjects
willingly to earn some extra money and I
did a bunch of those to pay for to buy a
video camera so I can start practicing
this do-it-yourself filmmaking technique
I was trying to pioneer back then taking
you know digital what you would use on
video and then apply it to film and to
pay for El Mariachi so I did a medical
research study it was very famous and in
my book rebel without a crew that
chapter I was a human lab rat was really
famous because I got my arms chopped up
and they put speed healer on one and
placebo on the other and then cut it out
and did tests on it or I was doing a two
thousand dollars for that for only seven
days or I did a cholesterol-lowering
drug that one made it on the market
speedy healer I've never seen on the
market so I think I tested that all for
nothing but
to my character in my new movie called
red eleven I was redshirt 11 when I was
in that last study to do mariachi cuz
each drug is on a different color shirt
so the Blues are on the antidepressants
the yellows are on the narcotic
painkiller the Reds were on the you know
speed healer drug and there was 15 in
our group and I was red 11 that's how
they know who's who so that's the name
of the movie there's a character kind of
based on me but I turned it into a
thriller so he's not sure if they're
trying to kill him in the hospital over
its side effects from the drugs the
reason I wanted to turn it into a
thriller because it's a funny comedy at
the sociological study of these
characters in there is funny enough as
it is the reality of it but I wanted to
document myself making a film about it
because I wanted to make for the 25th
anniversary a new movie for $7,000 over
the years rebel without a crew has
become a Bible for film students but
they've always asked me to do like a
follow-up that was for the digital age
because I shot that on film so I thought
well it's seen as believing though the
only thing about the drawback to rebel
without a cruise you just reading about
my exploits you're not seeing me
actually do it when you see someone make
a film by themselves with no money and
then you see the film it's a real
eye-opener very empowering to a
filmmaker to realize if you have an idea
for a story and if no one believes in
you not even your best friends you can
go out tomorrow make it yourself and put
it in a festival so this shows you how
to the documentary shows you how to
write shoot at its score cut your own
movie you see me do it from beginning to
end and we're gonna have on Tuesday at
the film festival is here at South by
Southwest not to give a masterclass for
an hour well I'll show only like 30
minutes from that select scenes from
that documentary because it's about a
two-and-a-half hour docu-series and then
right away we watch the movie and you
will not believe the movie when you see
even though you see me making it it
looks so much bigger and the ideas are
really clever and no money solutions and
it's really inspiring I think it really
inspired the way that book did even more
so because you're seeing it it's like
light bulbs will go off on even if you
don't make a movie on how you can jack
the system in a way to do anything that
you want to accomplish well it's
interesting because when you made
mariachi there
no video option the way there is now I
mean ice you know soda Berg's making
phones I'm making films on his iPhone
the technology that exists for the
average person is unbelievable so saying
that what camera did you use
I used a cannon what is this canon c300
so I use it 300 cuz I shot it in 4k
imagine the moodini would cost 7000 I
haven't spent all the money yet it's I'm
gonna spend it all cuz I got it to spend
I'm gonna give I'm gonna have to give it
to people as extra bonus but it was so
inexpensive cuz he just shows you in the
in the documentary you just have to
refuse to spend so if you have a decent
camera and a great story you can be
really clever on how to make something
that looks so much bigger I didn't just
do a talking head movie I went and did
something that was a sure thriller
action horror tons of actors it's a huge
cast it actually shouldn't have been the
movie I would do for seven thousand I
should have done something more like El
Mariachi that's less people and just
action but I was so perfect that this is
the one unmade story that I still had
from that era before I got known as a
filmmaker and it was about the medical
research hospital where I wrote el
Mariachi that's the reason I'm doing
that I mean the snake eating the tail
was just incredible in this movie and my
one crew member my boom guy my sound
recorder is my son who was my age
my age when I was doing those tests so
he co-wrote the script with me because I
knew he would have a connection to being
that age again it was like taking a time
machine back my older self helping my
younger self make his dream project
because in rebel without a crew I'm
talking about that story pitching it to
the studios it says in the book that's
the once life experience I add back then
that was the story I was trying to sell
and never could sell during the rebel
without a crew book so it made sense to
finish it now and it worked out
amazingly III did it just to kind of
instruct people on how to do it and it
ended up inspire me in a whole other way
it was it's a very profound experience
to go back and see that you could do it
again but learn really what creativity
is about again in a different way how
long was your shoot I gave I did a TV
series where I gave other diverse
filmmakers $7,000
to do a feature in 14 days because that
was just how long it took me to do
mariachis so that became the rules and
you could only have one helper I mean
mine was my son or you could bring a DP
or somebody like that I just used my son
14 day shoot $7000 I mentored them they
all made films but I did one also and I
did mine to show you how to do it and it
ended up being just like a profound
experience but I all the limitations I
had on mariachi that just became the
limitations you were given and I found
because I believe that if rich resources
are stripped away creativity dominates
it just it just shows up in droves
because when you're making a big film
you got a crew you're flying in actors
you've got equipment [ __ ] magic better
happen because that's what you're
setting it all up for but when you don't
have any of that when you purposely
strip it all away that's the only thing
holding the movie up and it's
awe-inspiring to be watching and going
oh my god they have nothing and it's so
entertaining it's you're looking at pure
magic happen it's really makes me want
to do one of these every year as a
palate cleanser I mean it's really and
you own it and it's it's incredible
everyone is so inspired all the actors
just didn't want to leave the set you
could just feel it was different than
any other movie I done I really blew me
away what is the distribution plan for
people to be able to see the movie after
self um I'm gonna sell it here
I mean it's mine to sell so I'm gonna
sell it I want to try to find someone
who can buy it ideally they would buy
both the docu-series and the film and
show it together like on a streaming
service because when you see the doc it
really wants to make you see the movie
you just want to see how it turned out
and when you see the movie you can't
believe what you're seeing you really
want to see how it was made so they
really go hand in hand so I think it
should be done as a package but we'll
see
I mean if it's somebody just wants the
movie I'll probably cut like a 40-minute
doc to put right at the end credits cuz
when you watch the movie totally stands
on its own you watch the movie and it's
very very entertaining
but then when you see it being made it's
like oh my god that I'm gonna go do that
right I mean inspires you to want to go
do that right then say what am i what am
I waiting for you
you have a limit limited shoot limited
money what's the thing in the script
that was the biggest obstacle in terms
of how do we make this happen with our
limitations was there and when you're
writing it are you thinking as you're
writing we really have to be careful
because we only have so much money and
so much time yeah I mean that's that's
kind of easy if you're gonna make a
movie my own advice even back a mariachi
was right around what you have don't
write something you got the power of the
pen don't put some in the script you
don't have and now now you got to wait
for that or need that or get that look
at what you have in reverse engineer so
I didn't spend anything really on the
movie I shot in my hallways of my
offices cuz that's kind of what the
hospital look like the one thing I had
to buy was the color t-shirt costumes
because we all had different color
shirts that that's kind of how you could
tell this them apart but I didn't put
logos on them like we had in the real
hospital that would it cost too much I
went on cheap tees dot-com
they had dollar fifty colored shirts
even though I needed 15 red shirts
twelve blue shirts I got eight red
shirts six blue shirts four yellow
shirts and every time it cuts we take
off the shirts of okay put up on the
other guy
we spent 50 bucks on that costume I mean
there's like no money on the screen
you're just using what you have but it
was a bigger
I shouldn't have really done that movie
I just wanted to do one more ambitious
because there's so many actors to shoot
a shot you have to have all these
colored shirt background guys in the
back and be wrangling all them yourself
usually you have an ad or you have a
second ad wrangling everybody so
logistically it was more difficult but I
needed to do this story this is the
story that made sense and I was
surprised that it actually benefited so
much I thought I was shortchanging this
really kind of cool idea about this
hospital trying to do outtime Research
Hospital and $7000 it's probably not
gonna look very good looks fantastic I
mean I I'd taught me a big lesson too I
mean when I'm learning still after doing
this before I know the audience is gonna
get so much by seeing this the light
bulbs are gonna go off in their head to
where they don't think anymore about
what they don't have they'll start
thinking more about what what they do
have and what they can do instead of oh
it's impossible your idea of what's
impossible changes by the time you've
seen this doc in that movie
everyone has been coming in or a lot of
people have been coming in we've been
playing get to know yourself by
Southwest attendee I'm very curious on
some of these answers for you I swear
these are harmless questions what TV
show would you love to guest write and
direct can it be of any era any era
Starsky and Hutch that's just the first
thing that popped in my movie Miami Vice
do you have a favorite sci-fi or fantasy
film that you have not been involved in
a favorite sci-fi or fantasy ship Flash
Gordon first came to mind
let me see sci-fi fantasy film god I
just love the first Terminator still my
favorite sci-fi action film do you have
a favorite superhero movie the original
Superman Richard Donner's yeah it's
fantastic yeah I mean just because that
was the first superhero movie I saw as a
kid and it was so magical sitting there
I don't know what I was eight eight or
nine the music came on it was John
Williams music so you could tell even at
that age because of Star Wars and jaws
had come out
it just felt and everyone was in awe
when he flew they couldn't believe that
they'd never seen that before
the fact that purity was really fun the
tag line and the poster is you would
believe you yeah why and that line is a
hundred percent of that yeah you know
what films scared you as a kid well I
saw jaws on my birthday because it came
out on my birthday when I was seven yeah
this came out June 20 of 1975 so that
one scared the hell out of me did you
like skip going in the water for like
ten years oh yeah yeah
but I also wanted to be an oceanographer
for a long time and I've dove with
sharks a bunch time since because it's
still played in my head is there
anything that you collect what do I
collect guitars have way too many
guitars one more than too many and one
less than not enough do you have do you
own more than 50 I probably own more
than 50 but that's not because I bought
them all people whenever I work with
somebody they want to give me a gift
they just give me a guitar so my friend
of mine who is a guitarist comes over to
my house and goes it's like me having a
bunch of cameras okay I don't even play
that much I mean I have a band and I do
play but you can ever play 50 guitars I
probably have part of 50 guitars
did you remember your first TV or movie
crush I just answered this question and
my wife got mad at me but it was like I
said I was a fine I was eight years old
he's like it was I was on Fantasy Island
very fantasy oh I do yes there is an
episode where this woman dressed like a
rooster she was wearing a bikini and a
rooster tail and I was like eight years
old did the math maybe was nine years
old I saw when it was released okay I
mean I was nine and I just thought she
was the most beautiful person I'd ever
seen it turned out to be barbi Benton
well there you go these barbi Benton um
do you own any movie or TV show props oh
yeah yeah yeah oh you have a bunch my
favorite is I did an interview with
George Miller and he was this favorite
interview it was a director's chair
episode and he said that's the best
interview I've ever given I'm gonna send
you a present for my birthday he sent me
the wheel from fury road I know and he
said there's two of these left in the
world I've got one you got the other one
that's like oh so I'm putting it over my
feet seven people will come in and
they're like oh and then we're watching
the movie my kids and they're all
holding it up and they're going it's
mine that's mine I go no look it's like
that's probably the best one we got a
few other good ones but that's that's
really never getting better than that
that's pretty freakin cool that I'm
ready to play there's just some amazing
shots of it always like up in the air
hold on I hate a witness you do you
what's a background photo on your phone
it changes almost daily what is it today
though oh is it like an auto changer I
just change it all the time because I
have a whole bunch on reserve and I got
all these texts on here I'll show you
what it is oh I love this poster it's a
poster of notorious it's an Italian
poster it's amazing
it's like in my house and it's huge and
I'd loved it so much I even carried on
my phone even though I can see it every
day it went back to black but that's
that's actually really really cool it's
just a badass version of that poster
yeah that's a very cool poster do you
where was I up to what TV show have you
watched all the way through
more than once if any you know my wife
and I love watching moonlighting
remember the Bruce Lee show was so funny
in that and that serious she was great
too
and we loved the screwball comedies like
the Cary Grant and you know what's
up-dock is also a great one and that
carried that vibe of the screwball
comedy tons of dialogue really fat know
how they pulled that off on a TV
schedule but he would tell me stories
about that every time on how how
difficult it was their scripts were like
twice as long so we watched those
because those are fun no I was gonna say
it's these are it's real quick it's
these are called visser that's Star Wars
or Star Trek [ __ ] I really love the old
Star Trek I watched the old Star Trek's
more than the old Star Wars okay a game
of Thrones or Breaking Bad Breaking Bad
and the last one han solo or indiana
jones indiana jones horrible ending now
you can't you can't see it was funny I
gave my son this really cool bag it was
an amazing leather bag and we need to
open it up to a Star Wars bedsheets in
it and you'd open it up and Han Solo is
in there but after the last movie he
opens it up and Tong he was like oh no
it's like a curse now he's like not cool
anymore it's like that's how you're
gonna die okay that's he's like a cursed
person now you ruined him I'm leaving it
alone and I'm just gonna say I cannot
wait to see the movie and I'm actually
really I really can't wait to see the
documentary that goes with it just
because I think what you do with this is
very inspiring to a lot of people and a
lot of people in your position don't do
stuff like this that's just been my DNA
from the beginning I was always telling
people how I did stuff because I knew I
would have appreciated that as a young
filmmaker and whenever I learn anything
even to their peers I would let them
know because when it makes you forces
you to learn new tricks but I know
people will just get inspired to know
that they they can empower themselves to
go do something themselves because even
if you're just frustrated with the
industry or if you're a woman or a
minority or someone who feels like their
voice isn't being heard you can go make
a movie yourself and using these methods
that they don't teach in film school I
invented them by accident
and by trying it again using those
methods because I thought there's
something about that method with
absolutely nothing I mean I did it that
way the first time because I had to but
this time what if I did it on purpose
like a petri dish I said what would
happen and you're gonna be stunned when
you see what the movie is and you're
gonna know it's not because I'm really
skilled it's because I was just rolling
camera when creativity shined on it
because they saw how impossible a task
you were taking on it shows up there
more than to the set that's got like all
this pageantry of a giant crew and a
giant cast it's like almost it smiles
more on those who have nothing and
you'll see that you'll witness that on
that note thank you so much for coming
in thank you to our sponsors and again I
can't wait to see it thank you so much
thanks
you